he feels like you don't really that you
don't bring a lot to the table rally
have people ever told you that in your
life before or not oh all the time
i got a silent assassin here with me
today or semi-silent
and this is a young fella named riley
mao
and um what is riley short for bud
riley okay man okay so nothing see back
in the old days you'd have a longer
name you know rilandro you would be you
know rolandro
or you know lowrily or something longer
and riley would be short for something
right nope i'm just riley
okay all right beautiful man and you
um you have a favorite statue
can't say i do
you gotta have one man you should get
one i like uh i'll tell you a couple of
mine you're welcome to board if you need
what there's one
in um there was the tallest bob
hope statue and that was in uh
duran i believe it was duran illinois
can you look that up actually do you
mind really now
um i hate to put you to work there but
you got to do something you know um
tallest bob hope statue you know
11 more people smoking crack near you
and you're just wondering how it all
financially made sense what do you have
a tallest bob hope statue
any information oh you wanted bob hope i
looked up the statue of hope
in uh friendship indiana
oh okay what is that it is
a private memorial or monument displayed
in a graveyard or cemetery hope is one
of the seven virtues of the christian
religion so it's literally just about
hope
oh that's beautiful not bob hope but
okay
well that's close enough man if if you
get that bob hope intel let us know
riley now you got any information on
that uh bob hope statue
i do so it says that bob hope may be
something of a forgotten figure as
a los angeles times writer said in a
november 29 story
about a new biography on late comedian
hope entertainer of okay what about the
statue bubba
there is a nine foot five inch tall
fiberglass and cement uh statue
that has stood for 34 years in
rockford rockford illinois yes sir wow
yeah man that's beautiful now something
this yeah something you see different
places small
towns like to do that and like to honor
something
tall a statue bob hope did he ever go
see it does it say
and there you go ladies and gentlemen
that's riley mal right there
you that rain riley i do
it's cool huh yeah that's it's a lot
that's a lot man that's cool
excuse my language man excuse my
language also riley
not a problem okay do you where you're
from do you guys use a lot of profanity
or what is it like over there so
i am a christian um and
an eagle scout um i don't do swearing at
all
okay um that's just not me but i mean
hey i don't i don't judge
okay well you can judge me i'm gonna let
you know that
awesome you can judge me up until the
point that i'm willing to accept it
and then i'm gonna try to use less of it
around you then
all right i might write some of the
words down and show you some of the ones
in advance that i'm going to use from
now on just
i just don't want there to be not fair
communication sure
okay right cool man i'm spending all
this [ __ ] dorm money on
oh and why did he have to curse you
think right there
riley now who knows it's just how how he
talks
yeah okay
you're right you're right onward rally
meow hit us with a news item brother
well in a british wildlife park they
have removed five cursing parrots from
public
okay when you say cursing parrots what
do you mean like parrots that they're
what
casting spells on on public
i mean that they have foul language
oh vowels have foul language okay
and any other information they're giving
you
um it just says that the birds shared
the ability to curse up a storm
something they engaged in quite often
okay so they're doing it and where is it
happening you said
in a british wildlife park yep
yep have you disappointed a woman in
your life riley mal
oh have i i definitely have
and how do you feel about it now and now
that some time has passed
fell in love for a pregnant woman pretty
much and i had no idea
because she wasn't showing yet so it was
it was very early in the stage
and i i literally had no idea that
pregnancy the first three months it can
trick you
you it used to be back in the old days
riley a woman had a decent womb in her
you know about it you heard about it
yeah definitely
were you breach birth riley i was not
all right man well let's there's
different ways to do it let's get into
the episode
do you have any birth defects or
anything like that um
can't say i have um i mean i'm a
musician
like i said but when you were born were
you missing anything did you have any
birth defects
um dang dude i'm not sure i don't think
so
okay so straight up full birth yeah
wow must be nice man have you ever had
any small animals
i have i had a dog when i was little
okay that's great you ever done any
injectable drugs raleigh now
i mean unless it's for surgery um the uh
what do you call it the thing that makes
you go to sleep for surgery
other than that no anesthesia you mean
yep that
okay that's the thing but you never just
you know
you and your buddy you know never pulled
off the interstate and done steroids or
anything like that
nope unfortunately not do you do cocaine
really
i don't all right so what this man is
asking about is they'll have um
one of those fountains like a fake
stone fountain where the little guy is
urinating into the birdbath you know
what i'm talking about riley
you ever seen those or not i've seen
them everywhere
you have i have okay and when you see
that what do you feel like what is that
what is that is that cool is that lame
what is it
i mean i i just don't really
i don't really have an opinion i just i
see it and i just
disregarded i i mean i couldn't care
less
honestly okay and there you go that's
the young perspective
they don't care any parting words you
have riley
no not at all
hi my name is henry i'm in middle school
and well i'm pretty good with the ghost
staff i train
almost every day and i hear that riley's
asian so that's pretty much a given that
well he's in martial arts so
i challenge him to a duel
uh gang riley you got a child right
there challenging you
could you beat a child in a contest i
yeah i'm pretty sure i can you think you
can beat that kid's ass honestly henry
um i mean i don't know he he might be
faking the faking the voice he might be
like a really tough guy
i don't know and how would you approach
it you think
well i mean i would tell them you know
come over to
come over to the middle east and we'll
uh we'll hash it out
okay so there you go you got a real
challenge right there he's saying bring
it over
to the central east you mean
bring it over to the central east it'll
hash it out
you know and that's tell you right there
people want to d uh
doubt on raleigh mao he'll just he just
offered to beat the [ __ ] out of a damn
middle schooler
so you know anybody that's been serial
killed riley
i don't no well
live a little brother i have two friends
who's have uh family members have been
victims of serial killers or sks they
call them
i'll do the egg hunts over there
for easter yeah um
no well are you talking about church or
like just in general church
uh church no okay well
could be a good church could not be a
good church i'm not saying anything
about eastside man
you know they sound like it sounds like
a great outfit but it you know
hide an egg you ever sin like you guys
do a time capsule for
christ or anything like that through
church you guys do a
you know send a rocket up to god or
anything was there any fun stuff like
that you did as
children um not not for uh religious
purposes but i mean i've done time
capsules i've done
rockets um my dad's a rocket engineer
oh dang yeah yeah um
have you ever done it forgot you guys
ever built something for the lord and
just jacked that thing up into the sky
no i can't say i have not for the lord
i've just done it for fun
damn damn you living man i like talking
a lot
um other than that um wow yeah i'm i'm a
pretty quiet dude other than that um
football is finally back do you watch
football riley now
i'm not a big fan okay great man are you
paying attention riley
i am indeed okay you seem like you're
not but that's all right
oh no i definitely am okay thank you
brother i do not believe you but i do
appreciate that
you know we have a lot of nice people
listen to this podcast
riley mao
all right um
oh i remember this man you know
halloween is coming up
and i remember that uh riley i wanted to
ask you
what you thought about that do you guys
practice that
what is some of your experience with
that um
honestly uh i don't have an opinion
i don't honestly all right
um do you remember ever being costumed
as a child did anybody dress you up and
kind of trick you out at different areas
for sugar you know what i'm talking
about halloween
what do you think riley you had an
experience with anything like that
i have not honestly
what else is going on man i'll say this
uh i quit using the n-word probably
about four years ago when everybody else
did
fully i mean i would never actively you
know
but people would you know you know you
look at asians there's and there's also
all different what i don't like is get
specific with the racism
these asians you know i've said it i've
definitely said it
i'll be honest with you oh yeah everyone
has yeah you have a lot of body hair
rally
i don't
i would have guessed that man honestly
really yeah
and i hate to be now is that racism
if i guessed that you know what i'm
saying kind of right now i get it um
on it kind of yeah you got your patrick
mahomes is out there
this guy i mean who knows what he's
doing this dude do anything he wants
you got who's somebody that's mixed that
does well riley
um me
who else i'm trying to think of a female
there's definitely other people
but here's what i'm saying is that this
i think eventually all the ra every race
will be mixed
in two three centuries you're gonna have
everybody is gonna be
part everything do you know any rally
any
rate what groups that have racial
tension
um
japanese and germans there you go i feel
like if you are black
white uh malaysian whatever
right feeding a bread to a duck is
normal
right i've seen literally anybody i
could imagine
doing it right exactly amen the man was
smoking crack and then made one of the
most successful pillows of all time
you know name another can you name
another pillar riley
um yeah the uh
what do you call it um
you can't think of it because you can't
think of it dude and that's why
the uh therapy therapeutic um no
no no that's a mattress you're
you're talking tempo yeah you're right
yep pillow is just for your head
mattress is for your body right what's
up big daniel
out of northeast arkansas you ever been
there raleigh
i've not well actually what is northeast
arkansas like what cities
man is anything else you want to share
with us riley
um i did see that a man told
snakeskin isn't a legitimate face
covering
there you go
[Music]
there you go riley mao anything else you
need to say man
no i think this was a uh this was great
i loved being here
great to be here i like your attitude
brother
i like your attitude man you've read rib
damage riley mao
i have not and i don't want to
there you go folks the hot take
from raleigh mail baby what's a good
sound you think riley mal
i mean good sounds as in
like just anything in general like a
good sound yeah
um i mean laughter is a good sound um
i don't know rocket flying into space is
a good sound an elephant
i like elephants elephants are a good
sound
indiana it's a spanish four
in indiana indian
oh indian i did not know that a lot of
comedians
will end up getting into music
riley now do you know that i do now
def signaling you know what what is that
called you know what i'm talking about
riley and
hand gestures um what's the name of it
i think it's death signaling covington
that's my hometown
where'd you do did you know i was from
somewhere riley
i did not know exactly where
well i am from covington louisiana do
you know what it's famous for
cheese oh wait that's wisconsin
yep nope it is famous for
tallest statue of ronald reagan in
america
do you have any trouble looking at
pornography or anything like that i
don't
wow really god
and have you always been that way oh
man and how do you do it you think
i mean i just don't there's not really a
how
i just don't
remarkable buddy okay
[Music]
and this is a young fella named riley
mao fella named riley mao
young fella named riley mao fella named
riley mao
i'm just riley riley riley
i'm just riley young fella named riley
mao
you have a favorite statue i can't say i
do okay man
you that rain riley i do cool huh
homework where you're from do you guys
use a lot of profanity or what is it
like over there um
i don't do swearing at all okay [ __ ]
face if you disappointed a woman
in your life riley man oh have i
i definitely have okay and how do you
feel about it now
and now that some time has passed
because she wasn't showing yet
i literally had no idea yep and this is
a young
fella named riley mao fella named riley
mao
young fella named riley mao fella named
riley mao
i'm just riley riley riley
i'm just riley young fella named
it used to be back in the old days riley
a woman had a decent womb in her
you know about it you heard about it
yeah you know about it you heard about
it
yeah will you breach birth riley no
did you have any birth defects i can't
say i have um i'm a musician so straight
up full birth
it's a straight up full birth you ever
done any injectable drugs riley man
oh have i i definitely have you do
cocaine really
kind of yeah okay and when you see that
what do you feel like
couldn't care less could you beat a
child in the contest
i'm pretty sure i can i would tell them
you know who you're talking to riley
he just offered to beat the [ __ ] out of
a damn middle schooler
didn't care less and this is a young
fella named riley mao
fella named riley mao young fella named
riley mao
fella fella named riley i'm just riley
riley riley i'm just riley young fellow
named riley mao
you know anybody that's been serial
killed riley i don't
y'all do the egg hunts over there for
easter yeah
no okay well hot an egg
who's somebody that's mixed that does
well riley me
northeast arkansas you ever been there
raleigh
nope i've not well actually what is
northeast arkansas
[Music]
football is finally back do you watch
football riley now
i'm not a big fan i'm not a big fan
okay elephant i like elephants elephant
i like elephants
elephant i like elephants elephant i
like elephants
do you have any trouble looking at
pornography or anything like that
i don't remarkable buddy
and this is a young fella named riley
mam fella named riley mao
young fella named riley mao fella named
riley mao
i'm just riley riley riley
i'm just riley young fella named riley
there you go there you go the heart take
from riley now baby
you